يواصل رجال الانقاذ سباقهم مع الزمن
لمحاوله انقاذ الناجين لكن سوء الاحوال
الجويه يعقد المهمه وفق صحيفه
وقد حذر وزير الداخليه التركي يوم
الثلاثاء من ان الساعات الثمانيه
والاربعين القادمه ستكون حاسمه للعثور على
ناجين في بعض الاحيان يكون الامر معجزه
كما هو الحال في جندريس على الجانب السوري
حيث اخرجت رضيعه حديثه الولاده من تحت
الانقاض وهي ما تزال متصله بواسطه الحبل
السري بوالدتها المتوفاه
الكاتب سامسونج في صحيفه الجارديان
البريطانيه قال ان صوره رجل تركي يمسك بيد
ابنته بعد وفاتها توضح عمق ماساه الزلزال
ويضيف الكاتب ان مسعود هانسر جلس بين
الانقاض ممسكا بارميك البالغه من العمر 15
عاما وهي مستلقيه على فراشها تحت الواح من
الخرسانه والنوافذ المحطمه والطوب المكسور
الذي كان يوما ما شققا
الجارديان نشرت ايضا صورا التقطتها
الاقمار الصناعيه لما قبل الزلزال وبعده
للمناطق المنكوبه في سوريا وتركيا واظهرت
الصور للمدن القريبه من مركز زلزال تحول
مباني باكملها الى انقاض وركام وتعطي صور
الاقمار الصناعيه فكره عن حجم التحدي الذي
يواجه اطقم الطوارئ خلال الايام المقبله
كما انها تظهر بتفاصيل حيه حجم الدمار
الذي حدث البلدات والمدن والقرى في جميع
انحاء المنطقه
على صعيد سوريا تخشى صحيفه الفرنسيه من ان
بشار الاسد لن يسمح بوصول كثير من
المساعدات الانسانيه الى مناطق الثوار
الاسد سيضمن بالتاكيد براي لوفيجارو ان
تمر المساعدات جميعها عبر دمشق وليس عبر
تركيا كما هو الحال حاليا في مناطق الثوار
وبالتالي يظهر انه يمارس سلطته السياديه
على كامل المنطقه لكن الاولويه في
المساعدات من دمشق ستكون للسكان الموالين
للنظام وستهمل الاخرين حسب الصحيفه جدف
هوبارد وهي استاذه مساعده في علوم الارض
والغلاف الجوي في جامعه كورنيل قالت في
الواشنطن بوست ان الزلازل الكبيره هي
دائما مفاجاه ولا مفر منها لكنها استدركت
بان الماضي دليل جيد لما يجب فعله اذ يمكن
الان تطبيق الدروس المستفاده من الزلازل
السابقه في ويمكن ان تكون هذه الكارثه
بمثابه تحذير للاستعداد للزلازل القادمه
ولفتت الكاتبه الى انه بينما تجلب الزلازل
معاناه لا توصف فانها يمكن ان تؤدي ايضا
الى تغيير ايجابي وقد ساعد زلزال سومطر
عام 2004 على انهاء حرب اهليه اذ اجتمعت
طرفا للتركيز على التعافي